امس الاثنين كان في مباراه في دوري
المجموعات في كاس العالم بين البرتغال
والارغواي والمباره كانت ناريه وانتهت
بفوز البرتغال بهدفين مقابل لا شيء وبكده
بتكون خلاص البرتغال نقدر نقول ضمنت
تاهلها لدور ال 16 لكن في تفصيله في
المباراه قال بالدنيا حرفيا وخصوصا على من
الصاج وبين محبي ومتابعي الرياضه و
رونالدو تحديدا في اول اهداف البرتغال عام
الجدول والجدل هو حول مين اللي سجله فاللي
صار انه الكره طلعت من رجل او من رجل
اللاعب
رونالدو رونالدو
تحديدا وشفنا كل القنوات
كمان كاتبه الهدف لرونالدو لكن ما في
دقائق الا وكانت كل المواقع والقنوات
بحال هدف وحسبته لفرنانديز وقالت انه
الكره اتضح انها ما لمسه راس رونالدو
ورونالدو كان ردت فعل في الملعب وضحك في
الملعب اللي تابع المباراه اكيد شاف ملاحظ
انه من لحظه منعاد الهدف وبدات النقاشات
انه يا جماعه فين لمسها وشيء يقول ايه
والمسها وشيء يقول لا لكن عموما التقنيات
الجديده مخليه الكره الان فيها سنسنس وبطل
قلت لمسه اي احد للكره وبحسب الفيفا الكره
ما لمسه راس رونالدو والهدف ان حسب لي
فرنانديز لكن من وقت المباراه والدنيا
مولعه في كل من الصوت وبيان المحللين
والمختصين وحتى المتابعين العاديين
والسؤال هو مين سجل الهدف فعليا والاراء
مختلفه على فكره والتفسيرات مختلفه كمان
في رايي الشخصي هو تقريبا في برنامج بنسبه
100% مش بس ان موقع الفيفا اثبت كده ورجع
في كلامه بعد ما اقل كرستيانو رونالدو
صاحب الهدف لكن
حسب موقع فيفا نفسه حسب واحد من اهم
الرعاه التكنولوجيين بالنسبه لكاس العالم
2022 اللي دائما بعد كل هدف بيجيب بعض
الاحصائيات مين اخر لاعب لمسها سرعه الكره
قد ايه اتجاه الكره قد ايه مين اللي حرك
مسار الكوره كل هذه الاموره فموقع الفيفا
اعتمد على ده في النهايه نعتمد ان خلاص
دلوقتي رونالدو ما قدرش لو انت ركزت حتى
على الفيديو الهدف هتشوف انك كريستيانو
رونالدو حرفيا الكره ما بتغيرش الكره ما
تغيرشارها ما فيش ادنى تاتش او ادنى لمسه
كريستيانو رونالدو همم انا شايف الهدف
المفروض يحتسب لكريستيانو رونالدو صحيح
للوحده الاولى لما همم اللي عدى الاولانيه
ظهرت كان يبدو ان هو لما لبسهاش ولكن في
اعداد كثير همم ظهرت بعد المباراه اوضاعت
انك كريستيانو والله ماسك الكوره حتى لو
لمسه بسيطه والهدف بيحتسب لاخر لاعيب لمس
ال- الكوره همم نقطه ثانيه برده انا
شايفها مهمه في الجدل همم اللي حاصل على
الهدف انه بشكل او اخر كريستيانو مساهم في
الهدف لانه لولا تحركه ومحاولته لعب
الكوره كان الحارس عرفت تحرك على الكره
العرضيه بسهوله ويقدر يمسكها ولكن محاوله
الرساله لعبه الكوره خدعت الحارس وتسببت
في الاخر ان الكره تدخل هدف
وجهه نظري الشخصيه انه صح الصور بعضها
بتبدو كانه لمسها لكن هذه الكره الموجوده
كره اديداس فيها حساس عالي التقنيه بالمس
وبقيس اقل لمسه فلو فعلا لمسها كانت الكره
اعطت اشاره لمسها لكن بما انه القرار كان
بعدم الكره فهذا معناه انه رونالدو فعليا
ما اثر ابدا لا على سرعه ولا اي شيء
بالكره فهذا معنى ايضا انه رونالدو لمسها
وهنا بصير الهدف فعليا
هذه وجهه النظر لكن ايضا هذا الهدف كان
مستحيل يتسجل بدون رونالدو يعني عرضيه
بدون رونالدو يطلع ويشوش على الحارس
ويرلفت انتباه الحارس اكيد كان حارس في
كاس العالم مع الارجواي هيتولاه رونالدو
جزء من الهدف لكن ليس من سجلوا
اعتقد انه كريستيانو
واعتقد انه يعني شعره يعني شعر كريستيانو
فتقد انه هو الاحق زاد انه الاتحاد
البرتغالي قاعد يضغط على فيفا انه يحسب
الهدف له كريستيانو
خليني اقول لكم مشاهدينا ان الجدل والنقاش
مو مقتصر على الناس المتفرجين فحتى جوه
المنتخب نفسه الموضوع عام البلبله فاول
شيء صار انه الاعلامي بيرس مورجان واللي
مو من زمان عمل لقاء مع رونالدو قال انه
رونالدو بلغوا شخصيا انه راسه لمست الكره
يعني هو اللي سجل الهدف واللاعب فرنانديز
نفسه لي الصحفيين بعد المباراه قال انه
احتفلوا كانه رونالدو سجل الهدف وانه كده
شاف الملعب وانه هدفه اصلا كان يمرر
رونالدو الكره لكن قال كمان المهم انه
فزنا بغض النظر مين سجل هنا لازم نذكر انه
فرنانديز رجع سجل الهدف الثاني
للبرتغال من ضربه جزاء على فكره لكن
الموضوع كل ماله بيكبر يا جماعه فجاه شفنا
التقارير عن انه الاتحاد البرتغالي هيراسل
الفيفا رسميا بادله انه الهدف من حق
رونالدو والكره لمسته ورجعنا شفنا تاكيدات
بعدها من الفيفا انه التكنولوجيا اكدت بما
لا يسير اي شكل انه الكره ما لمسه رونالدو
وترى يعني غريب شويه الموضوع او غريب شويه
في المواد الموضوع جماعه انه الاتحاد
البرتغالي يراسل الفيفا عشان يحسب هدف
لرونالدو بدل فرنانديز يعني الاثنين
لاعبينك وفي نفس المنتخب اشمعنا جاءت
لنفسك تثبت انه الهدف ليه رونالدو اتجاه
هناك والتحليلات تطول بس علشان نحطكم في
الصوره كامله لازم نذكركم بكذا شيء اولهم
الازمات اللي بيعانيها رونالدو في مسيرته
الاحترافيه فسخ عقده مع مانشستر يونايتد
من كم يوم وفكره انه واحد من اهم لاعبين
الكره في العالم حاليا بدون نادي وغير
مرغوب وثاني شيء وهو الاهم انه رونالدو
اللي بيشارك في الخامس كاس عالم واللي
يسجل في كل الدورات اللي شارك فيها بيسعى
ونفسه ومنعينه قبل ما يعتزل انه يحقق كاس
العالم بلاده لو في هذا المونديال حتى
الان ما سجل الا هدف واحد فقط ومن ضربه
جزاء كان في هدف ثاني سجله لكن اللغه بسبب
انه نحسب فاول ضده يعني وعموما حتى الان
افضل شيء حققته البرتغال في كاس العالم
كيف 2006 لما حصلت المركز الرابع رونالدو
اذا نفسه يضيف كاس العالم لقائمه انجازاته
الحاليه خاصه وانه الان عمره 37 سنه ومع
انه ما اعلن انه هذا اخر كاس عالم لو
رسميه لكن يعني متوقع هذا الشيء في كاس
العالم الجاي هيكون عنده 41 سنه
وبالمناسبه هو اعلى في مقابلته مع البيس
مورجن انه لو كاس العالم هذا كسبه في
حيعتزل يعني واضح جدا لانه هذه البطوله هي
الشيء الاساسي اللي مخليه يكمل اللعب احنا
التفاعل لكم حبينا نعرف ارائكم انتم
مشاهدينا بما انه على
الاغلب اذا مو كلكم متابع له كاس العالم
ويحضرته المباراه بعد الجدل رجعته شفته
الهدف سالناكم انه مين برايكم سجل هذا
الهدف اجابتكم جاءت كالتالي 60% شايفين
حسب والهدف
لفيرنانديز و 40% تقريبا شايفينو ل-
رونالدو